[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre pour ce nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo je suis ravi de vous
accueillir ici au parlement européen à
bruxelles pour cette nouvelle saison
c'est parti pour une demi heure
d'actualité européenne dans cette
édition nous irons en espagne devenu ces
derniers mois la principale porte
d'entrée des migrants tentant de
rejoindre l'europe arrivé au pouvoir en
juin dernier le premier ministre
espagnol pedro sanchez avait marqué les
esprits en accueillant à bras ouverts
l'aquarius ce bateau humanitaire
transportant à l'époque 630 migrants que
l'italie et malte avait refusé de
laisser accoster
notre reporter s'est rendu dans le sud
de l'andalousie à algeciras ou seulement
quelques kilomètres séparent les côtes
africaines de l'union européenne nous
débattrons ensuite du dossier brûlant de
la politique migratoire européenne avec
nos trois invités
mais d'abord revenons sur le sujet qui
s'est placée au coeur de la rentrée
européenne cette europe fracturé par un
affrontement entre nationalistes et
progressistes lors d'une rencontre avec
le ministre de l'intérieur italien
matteo salvini à la fin de l'été viktor
orban
le premier ministre hongrois avait
désigné emmanuel macron comme son
principal adversaire
depuis deux camps se dessinent au sein
de l'union européenne je vous propose
d'écouter le président français qui
réagissait la semaine dernière sur ce
sujet au sommet informel de salzbourg
pour moi la crise que l'europe vit ces
dix des dix dernières années c'est une
crise existentielle
c'est la capacité à savoir si le projet
politique conduit par les pères
fondateurs qui a consisté très
clairement à savoir conjuguer les
intérêts nationaux pour définir quelque
chose de plus grand peut toujours
prévaloir
moi je considère que oui et c'est la
bataille que je vais mener
de là où je suis et c'est la bataille
que tous les progressistes en europe
doivent conduire que tous les démocrates
doivent conduire et face à ça il ya une
alternative fayet notre terme de
l'alternative simple ceux qui disent
cette europe ne marche plus il faut en
sortir en sortir totalement le break
site en sortir à la carte
je ne suis pas solidaire sur les
migrations ne suis pas solidaire sur
l'économie la finance au fond la briser
c'est ça le grand défi et c'est un
combat historique ce n'est pas une
élection comme les autres
et pour discuter de ce clivage 1 et de
la montée des populismes en europe j'ai
le plaisir de recevoir aujourd'hui
ramona comment bonjour bonjour vous êtes
directrice de l'institut d'études
européennes ici à bruxelles vous êtes
d'origine roumaine et vous connaissez
très bien ces démocraties d'europe de
l'est
viktor orban contre emmanuel macron les
populistes contre les progressistes
c'est sans doute l'opposition qui va
dominer toute cette année marquée
évidemment par le scrutin européen qui
arrive en mai prochain
l'union européenne selon vous pour tel
un danger à rentrer dans un débat aussi
frontale 1 oui tout à fait je pense
qu'il y avait ici à un danger mais je
voudrais tout d'abord dire que donc on
retrouve ici la stratégie de viktor
orban qui consiste à identifier des
ennemis qui consiste à créer des lignes
de démarcation entre eux et nous et donc
on voit ici tu es bien littoral qui se
pressent depuis quelques années comme le
défenseur de la lutte contre
l'immigration illégale et donc ils
pointent du doigt et manier le mâcon il
ne s'agit pas vraiment d'un clivage dans
le sens propre du terme
il s'agit d'une auto délimitation c'est
une étiquette a été proposée qui a été
imposé par un victor orban qui peut être
électoralement profitable il faut aussi
savoir que c'est dans le contexte des
élections européennes de l'année
prochaine viktor orban est en train de
construire un mouvement il s'appellerait
le mouvement avec les pays de visegrad
puce l'autriche éventuellement parce que
son objectif est justement de changer la
composition des institutions européennes
la composition du parlement la
composition du parlement européen de la
commission du parlement européen et donc
ils cherchent à trouver des alliés
il cherche à trouver des alliés au sein
du parti populaire européen et aussi de
manière générale des partis politiques
qui sont contre contre le multi qui
s'opposent au multiculturalisme et qui
sont favorables au renforcement des
frontières
alors justement victor b né le ministre
de l'intérieur italien ans matteo
salvini qui affichait en leur amitié à
la fin de l'été pourtant on sait que les
deux dirigeants et bien ne veulent pas
la même chose notamment sur le dossier
de l'immigration puisque l'italie
réclame plus de solidarité plus de
répartition alors que la hongrie refuse
toute idée en de quotas de répartition
finalement quels sont les points communs
entre l'italie de matteo salvini et ces
pays de l'est de l'europe selon vous a
priori il n'y a pas beaucoup de points
communs parce que la géographie et
l'histoire de ces pays surtout sur le
dossier de l'immigration sont très
différents mais justement matteo salvini
et viktor orban sont en train
d'identifier ces points pour la défense
d'une autre d'une autre d'une autre
europe et donc matteo salvini d'une part
cherche des alliés victor schoelcher si
des alliés et on sait très bien que pour
le moment les deux leaders sont divisés
sur la question de l'arrêt location à ce
que ben l'italie cherche à la
répartition cherche à répartir le nombre
de migrants alors qu'elle est pays de
visegrad s'y opposent alors le 12
septembre dernier a en tout cas le
parlement européen a voté pour le
déclenchement de l'article 7 à
l'encontre de la hongrie c'est une
procédure rare qui peut mener l'état
membres incriminés à être privé de son
droit de vote au conseil je rappelle
qu'en décembre dernier cette fois
c'était la commission européenne qu'il
avait activé contre la pologne
mais dans les deux cas et bien il ya peu
de chances que cette procédure aboutisse
un puisqu'on sait qu'elle nécessite un
vote à l'unanimité des états membres et
on sait que la pologne ne votera pas
contre la hongrie et inversement ce sont
finalement les mauvais élèves qui se
protègent entre eux mauvais élèves ou
base élèves je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas il y aura le vote est le soutien des
pays qui sont en train de mener
de développer des formes similaires dans
le domaine de la justice c'est donc ici
bien évidemment je fais référence à la
pologne
et comme vous l'avez très bien dit et je
pense que cette procédure ne va pas
aboutir parce que à mon avis cet article
c'était la procédure en tant que telle
n'a pas été inscrite dans les traités
pour adopter pour pouvoir adopter des
sanctions
et dès le départ c'était de pouvoir
mener un dialogue avec les pays
concernés
or ici ce que nous voyons clairement
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de dialogue et au
calme le dialogue n'a pas donné les
résultats
c'était parce que ton la pologne que la
hongrie sont allés très loin dans la
réforme de leur institution judiciaire
en adoptant des réformes qui mettent en
danger l'indépendance de la justice mais
aussi inamovible ils étaient des juges
d'accord et pour terminer ramona comment
j'aimerais rapidement abordé un autre
dossier brûlant du moment je pense
évidemment au brésil un dossier sur
lequel cette fois les états membres ont
plutôt parlé d'une seule voix en
refusant le plan de shaker sens proposé
par teresa may la première ministre
britannique je vous propose d'écouter sa
réaction
le référendum a été l'exercice
démocratique le plus important que ce
pays a jamais entrepris nier sa
légitimité ou aller à l'encontre de son
résultat menace la confiance du peuple
dans notre démocratie
c'est la raison pour laquelle depuis
plus de deux ans et j'ai travaillé jour
et nuit pour livrer un accord de sortie
de l'union européenne
les ce1 voie et j'ai travaillé pour
fédérer autour de moi même lorsque cela
ne semblait pas toujours possible
personne ne souhaite un accord viable
plus que moi mais que les choses soient
claires pour l'union européenne
je ne reviendrai pas sur le résultat du
référendum
je ne briserait pas non plus mon pays
nous avons besoin d'un engagement
sérieux pour la résolution des deux
grands problèmes des négociations et
nous nous tenons prêts étaient alors en
effet un même s'ils donnent elles tout
ce que le président du conseil ans s'est
voulu rassurant à l'issue du sommet de
salzburg la semaine d'un
en affirmant qu'un compromis bon pour
tout le monde était encore possible
on voit se dessiner la menace d'une
sortie sans accord d'un odile finalement
qu'est ce que cela signifierait à la
fois pour les britanniques et pour
l'avenir de l'union européenne
on est très en retard dans l'adoption de
cet apport de retrait mais aussi dans la
déclaration concernant les relations
futures entre londres et les 27 états
membres de l'union européenne fait son
retard parce que ces documents auraient
dû être prêt pour le 29 mars est donc
les documents devaient être approuvés
par les deux parlements
on est très en retard par rapport à quoi
par rapport à tout ça il y a quatre
points qui bloquent encore il ya la
question des frontières il ya la
question des appellations géographiques
et protéger la question de la cour de
compétence de la cour de justice et de
manière générale la gouvernance de
l'accord dont quatre points de blocage
en même temps je dirais aussi qu'il y à
déplomber qui se prépare parce que par
exemple il ya toute une partie de la
législation et de droit européen qui est
adoptée temporairement par les
britanniques pour pouvoir continuer à
dérouler leur activité dans différents
secteurs
à l'exemple le secteur des médicaments
j'ai entendu dire que par exemple en cas
d'absence d'accord il y aura par exemple
les relations commerciales vont être
régis par les dispositions de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
donc il y a quand même un certain nombre
de dispositions qui se met en place
donc il ya quand même beaucoup
d'incertitudes par rapport à tous ces
éléments là et puis le risque bien
évidemment est de voir des files aux
frontières salon j'ai appelé le 29 mars
est la date d'entrée en vigueur de cet
accord
merci beaucoup merci à main comme
éclairage on passe maintenant à l'autre
dossier qui agite le débat européen
particulièrement houleux en cette
rentrée celui de l'immigration avant
d'en parler avec nos invités je vous
propose de regarder ce reportage tourné
dans l'extrême sud de l'espagne en
andalousie alors que la route des
balkans et fermé que la grèce a vu les
arrivées nettement diminué depuis
l'accord de l'union européenne avec la
turquie et que la route de la libye est
rendue de plus en plus difficile par
l'augmentation des garde-côtes libyens
c'est la route espagnol qui est devenu
cet été le principal point d'entrée
voyez ce reportage signé jérôme bradés
[Musique]
à la pointe sud de l'andalousie
l'afrique est à portée de regard
même si les jours de brume
on distingue à peine la côte marocaine
et ses falaises 14 deux petits
kilomètres qui constitue désormais la
principale voie de passage des migrants
qui tentent de rallier l'europe pour
veiller sur ceux des trois comme chaque
jour dans le port d'algésiras le service
maritime de la guardia civil va prendre
la mer des zodiac et des vedettes
patrouillent dans les eaux sous
responsabilité espagnol soit jusqu'à 1
km des côtes marocaines
et cette année en à peine huit mois le
nombre de traversées a explosé
ghailani l'année dernière le chiffre a
atteint 5000 migrants simplement dans
cette zone et cette année on en est déjà
presque à 14000 juste dans la zone du
détroit donc en extrapolant on a
multiplié par quatre nos interventions
par rapport à l'année dernière qui
constituait déjà une forte augmentation
et en andalousie seulement on s'attend à
arriver à 40 45 mille personnes d'ici la
fin de l'année
les moyens de la guardia civil ont été
renforcées notamment par le déblocage de
fonds de l'union européenne et alors que
leur mission principale était de traquer
les trafiquants de drogue
ils scrutent désormais la mer pour
repérer les embarcations de migrants
tu peux me passer les jumelles s'il te
plaît devant la proue regarde à 11
heures
fausse alerte pour cette fois mais en
cas d' embarcations de migrants
ils vont systématiquement porter secours
à ceux qui prennent la mer dans des
conditions extrêmes notre mission c'est
la lutte contre l'immigration illégale
et dans cette lutte la première réponse
est de se courir ce sont des personnes
qui traversent sur des embarcations
surchargées
enfin des embarcations dans le meilleur
des cas mais le plus souvent dans ce que
nous appelons des jouets des bateaux
gonflables s'est joué que vous pouvez
acheter dans n'importe quelle boutique
de plage et si on n'allait pas les
sauver dirait par leurs propres moyens
ou il ce noir et comme malheureusement
cela se passe souvent aujourd'hui pas de
migrants récupérer mais quand le temps
est clément ils peuvent être plusieurs
milliers comme en juillet dernier des
camps d'accueil ont donc été monté en
urgence dans les environs d'alger six
races ou un tri est opérée les marocains
sont renvoyés immédiatement grâce à un
accord avec le royaume chérifien pour
les autres principalement venus
d'afrique de l'ouest
les associations prennent le relais un
phénomène pas si nouveau pour les
bénévoles d'algésiras accords et
l'accueil d'algésiras fondée en 1991
quand on appelait encore ces migrants
des boat people et la cnda corrida ici
c'est le premier lieu où ils arrivent
le bureau d'accueil de l'association
c'est là qu'on les reçoit et qu'on prend
en compte des demandes de chaque
personne ici chaque jour dix à quinze
migrants viennent chercher de l'aide
une activité intense et avec des moyens
insuffisants malgré l'image accueillante
de l'espagne à certains moments oui on
met les moyens nécessaires comme pour la
foire illustres mais une semaine après
ils arrivent ici sur la côte d'algésiras
et il n'y avait pas assez de moyens
matériels et les gens ont dû dormir par
terre dans des gymnases
car il n'y avait pas assez de lits pas
assez de policiers donc d'une part une
solution un peu
cosmétique et d'autre part la dure
réalité c'est que de nombreuses fois on
s'en occupe très mal car on n'a pas les
infrastructures suffisantes pour toutes
les personnes qui arrivent
pour ceux qui ne tente pas leur chance
ailleurs en espagne ou en europe
l'association met en place un parcours
d'intégration avec notamment des cours
d'espagnol
allez venez on va commencer aujourd'hui
ils sont une dizaine à venir suivre le
cours allons-y on va commencer la classe
d'espagnol certains sont un peu avancé
car ils sont là depuis quelques mois
d'autres sont nouveaux et on va donc
reprendre un petit peu au début ils
viennent d'afrique de l'ouest du maghreb
mais aussi des zones tribales entre
l'afghanistan et le pakistan et sont en
attente pour leur demande d'asile
mon nom est nisar je viens du pakistan
j'ai 21 ans et je viens à algeciras
l'espagne m'a beaucoup aidé a fait
beaucoup de choses pour moi pour le
logement pour pouvoir m'acheter à manger
et maintenant j'attends mes papiers et
après pour trouver du travail
la première chose est la plus importante
c'est de venir parler espagnol
face à cet afflux le sentiment de la
population est assez partagés sur la
nouvelle politique mise en place par le
parti socialiste espagnol et c'est là
aussi les autres pays ferment leurs
frontières
nous devons ouvrir nos portes pour aider
car qui sait un jour si nous n'aurons
pas besoin d'émigrer et à ce moment là
on trouvera les frontières fermées
je pense qu'il faut d'abord s'occuper en
premier des gens de la maison et après
si possible des gens de l'extérieur
moi ça ne me dérange pas de dire cela
même si ça a l'air raciste mais c'est
comme toi dans ta maison tu va d'abord
s'occuper de son enfant avant d'aider
ceux qui sont dehors si tu peux donc
pour moi c'est pareil
prête à tout pour s'intégrer nisar
espère avoir une réponse rapide de
l'administration pour pouvoir enfin
travailler à moins d'un an des élections
européennes
reste à savoir si le dossier migratoire
aura raison de l'île aux espagnols dans
un océan européen de progression et
populiste
[Musique]
et pour en discuter j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau juan lopez
aguilar bonjour bonjour vous êtes vous
faites partie du ps a eu le parti
socialiste ouvrier espagnol c'est le
parti de pedro sanchez et dans ce
parlement européen vous appartenait au
groupe des socialistes et démocrates
face à vous aujourd'hui
mario borghezio bonjour bonjour vous
êtes italien ans membre de la ligue qui
est le parti au pouvoir en italie avec
le mouvement 5 étoiles c'est notamment
le parti de matteo salvini le ministre
de l'intérieur italien et enfin pour
compléter ce plateau j'ai le plaisir de
recevoir frank engel bonjour bonjour
vous êtes membre du parti chrétien
social luxembourgeois et au parlement
européen vous appartenez au ppe le parti
populaire européen
alors pour commencer à juan lopez
aguilar on voit dans ce reportage le
président d'une association d aide aux
migrants parler de la dure réalité du
manque de moyens qu'il subit tous les
jours face à des solutions qu'il
qualifie de plus cosmétique car il fait
évidemment référence à cet accueil bras
ouverts de l'aquarius 1 par le premier
ministre espagnol on s'en souvient
c'était à valence on se souvient aussi
en août 1,2 ce renvoi collectif d'une
centaine de migrants alors qu'ils
avaient forcée à la clôture de ceuta
finalement selon vous est ce que ce sont
des signaux contradictoires envoyés par
le gouvernement espagnol sur sa
politique migratoire
les cantons avec science on dans un
niveau européen c'est pas un problème
espagnol c'est un problème est européen
surtout après l'entrée en vigueur du
traité de lisbonne la situation c'est
très difficile c'est tout à fait vrai
que l'espagne c'est le seul pays de
l'union européen qui a des frontières
terrestres avec le continent africain
c'est on fait les pays européens plus
proche au continent africain
et c'est tout à fait vrai que la
pression migratoire les flux le corps à
corps ont été déviés par conséquence de
la manque de solidarité avec l'italie
pour trop long de ton encore une fois
vers l'espagne et l'espagne a réagi et
l'espagne a eu un changement de
gouvernement en gouvernement en
socialiste et nous avons fait la
différence encore une fois nous avons
ayez la curieuse mais on doit rappeler
que l'espagne a fait face à cette
situation sont des concessions à la
sérophobie et au populisme et l'espagne
appel à la solidarité qu'est ce qu'un
mandat européen après l'entrée en
vigueur du traité de lisbonne la
solidarité c'est pas plus une volonté
c'est un mandat juridique contraignant
pour tous les pays européens et
l'espagne a rappelé la nécessité de
construire une réponse de niveau
européen
il nous faut la rançon européen pas
seulement la réponse espagnol et pas
seulement la réponse nationale dans
google alors c'est une politique
migratoire au niveau européen qui est
très difficile à trouver
frank engel une réaction à ce que disait
votre voisin un instant et la raison
dans la mesure où évidemment on ne peut
pas continuer éternellement à sa saison
passée la balle quand il ya quand il ya
un bateau avec des migrants qui doit
accoster tout ça lamentable
je trouve ça d'autant plus lamentable
que ça n'a rien à voir avec le phénomène
migratoire en tant que tel les chiffres
de ceux qui sont déjà en grèce en italie
en espagne aussi sont très très
largement supérieur à l'apport de
quelques centaines qui occasionnellement
se présente encore une fois suite à des
suites à des opérations de sauvetage en
mer et on devrait être capable de
trouver une logique pour les faire
accoster que ce que ce soit à mal que ce
soit en italie que ce soit ailleurs
logiquement à malte ou en italie par ce
sont les choses les plus proches mais en
même temps on ne peut pas éternellement
non plus faire une fois un grand geste
comme l'a fait perdre sans cesse avec le
premier accueil de l'aquarius à valence
est et ensuite dire bon enfin à partir
de maintenant ça nous concerne plus
alors justement la répartition des
migrants de l'aquarius en début de
semaine c'est une fausse solution un
politique passion c'est une cette
jeunesse est une solution c'est la
solution nécessaire parce qu'il n'y en a
pas d'autre et mon pays peuvent fait
régulièrement partie de ceux qui disent
volontairement on va en prendre une
dizaine
ou deux mais là encore quelques efforts
surhumains ça doit être pour n'importe
quel pays membres de l'union européenne
de dire vingt personnes on peut encore
peut-être les accommoder tout le monde
peut être commandé 20 personnes et
toutes les semaines donc a priori je
trouve je trouve ce spectacle plutôt
plutôt lamentable dans le sens où c'est
manifestement le cas aussi du ministre
de l'intérieur italien et le fait pour
la galerie beaucoup plus que pour la
substance parce que parra par rapport au
fardeau que porte l'état lit et tout le
monde le concède sans personne ne plus
200 personnes de plus ne constituerait
pas vraiment une augmentation du
problème c'est vrai que la grande
lamente habilité dans le dossier et
qu'effectivement nous avons laissé
l'italie seule comme nous avons glace et
la grèce seul avant et comme nous
laisserons seuls très vraisemblablement
l'espagne maintenant suite aux décalages
géographique t des principaux mouvements
parce que tous les autres s'en lave les
mains elles se disent que finalement
c'est assez bien qu'il doit y avoir
quelqu'un qui s'en occupe
tandis que tandis que nous n'aurons pas
besoin ça concerne d'ailleurs aussi la
france qui au delà des grandes
déclarations du président macron a très
très peu fait jusque là pour l'accueil
des migrants ce que je trouve
et bien pour le moins contestable alors
oui justement à cette aquarius il est
finalement devenu le symbole de la crise
qui divise l'europe mario borghezio
votre réaction
oui je pense que je cette situation
démontre la faillite de la politique
européenne sur l'immigration et les
exposants de ppp et de parti socialiste
européens ils ont confirmé avec un
jugement sévère mais ce qui a voté ses
directives
tombeuse sur l'immigration qui ont pas
eu une vision realistic de la énormité
de la pression virtuel mais aujourd'hui
réels des populations de l'afrique
on a laissé l'afrique seule pas
seulement l'italie seule l'afrique seule
parce que l'europe il dit
continuellement qui veulent aider
l'afrique mais les aides à l'afrique ont
été les aides aux militaires de
l'afrique au chef corrompu de but
plusieurs pays de l'afrique et et les
l'immigration continue parce que les
gens puis des situations terribles des
fois et donc il a il a décidé très bien
le gouvernement et en particulier le
ministre de l'intérieur italien a stoppé
cette hypocrisie et donc évidemment nous
sommes solidaires envers la situation de
l'espagne alors je mets les leurs qui a
été déterminé par la politique de
l'union européenne où nous nous étions
les seuls à au projet justement je
reviens sur l'espagne en particulier ce
renvoi de migrants en cet été
le ministre de l'intérieur italien ans
matteo salvini avait déclaré à l'époque
sur twitter si c'est l'espagne qui le
fait ça va mais si c'est moi qui le
propose je suis raciste fasciste et
inhumain oui nous notre gouvernement en
particulier monsieur charles vinit
lattes et objets il est actuellement
tous les jours l'objet d'un culte
fasciste non hagist et chez nos folles
il parce que il a décidé de fermer les
portes
mais c'est la seule solution pour
imposer à l'europe à cette europe
aveugle la réalité et la réalité c'est
que les peuples
ils veulent une immigration bien réglé
et chaque pays selon la possibilité
d'accueillir l'italie déjà fait alors
justement l'italie qui a le sentiment de
s'être retrouvé seul en face à cette
crise migratoire est ce que monsieur
aguilar ce sentiment est partagé
maintenant en espagne
je viens d'écouter ce que teddy par le
président de la ligue et je suis
d'accord que la politique migratoire de
l'union européen et oppressant faillite
mais j'ai pas d'accord avec les
diagnostics et j'ai pas d'accord avec la
thérapie
il y était infaillible justement parce
qu'il n'ya pas une politique migratoire
comment et les pays qui ont été sous la
pression d'une façon plus forts ont été
laissés seuls c'était les cadets
l'italie et c'est maintenant les cales
de l'espagne il faut construire une
politique européen d'abord et après il
faut construire à l'autre politique
alternative politique européen
parce que l'attitude négationniste c'est
un faillite l'absolu d'absence d'une
voie régulière
c'est à l'origine de ces fuites il faut
établir des voix régulière et une
approche plus positif plus constructif à
la politique migratoire et il faudrait
aussi changer selon les mandats des
parlements européens ce qu'on l'appelle
la relève en dédoublant deux doubles
envoie la réforme et le
le règlement dublin on a vu que c'était
pratiquement impossible ce serait pour
répartir les demandeurs d'asile parmi
les états membres mais certains pays
notamment le groupe devise gradins la
hongrie en tête refusent toute idée de
quotas de répartition il n'y a pas de
politique migratoire européenne et c'est
ça le problème ne peut pas être en
faillite parce qu'on n'a jamais existé
nous faisons de la politique de gestion
de crise
point final et le règlement de dublin
n'a jamais été fait pour gérer des
crises c'est un cetain c'est un jeune
batteur des artistes comme on dirait en
allemand une loi pour le goûtant et bien
évidemment elle a été conçue à un moment
où personne ne s'imaginait qu'en 2015
nous allions faire face à l'afflux que
nous avons connue en 2015 encore en 2016
mais à la fin du conte en 2017 et en
2018 nous en sommes à des chiffres
largement inférieurs à ce que nous avons
connu en caser en 16es on devrait être
capable maintenant de dire ok à la fin
du compte que fait que fait le règlement
de dublin
le règlement de dublin et de la
législation anti solidere par excellence
parce qu'alors trois précisément à des
pays comme l'italie
hier et aujourd'hui où la soul espagne
sans doute aujourd'hui la seule
responsabilité d'accueil rien d'autre
rien derrière
donc s'il ya une demi million de gens
qui arrivent à gauche ou en espagne
c'est l'espagnol qui sur la base de ces
textes doit s'en occuper
ça n'est pas normal c'est un souci n'est
pas normal ça défoule et nabeul et on
sait que à la suite de l'instabilité
politique que nous avons connue dans
notre voisinage géographique mais
également à la suite à l'éclatement de
la libye et de l'effondrement de l'état
en libye l'effondrement de l'état en
syrie et à la fin du compte de
l'effondrement de l'autorité de l'état
sur de très très large partie de
l'afrique
nous sommes en présence constante de
gens en mouvement par millions la très
très grande majorité de ces gens ne
quittent pas le continent africain il ya
infime minorité qui prétend le quitter
et nous faisons comme si nous avions en
face de nous une invasion un demi
million de personnes qui vont se
rajouter un demi milliard de personnes
c'est pas une invasion pour moi et si on
arrivait à les distribuer de façon
raisonnable équitable ce serait tant
mieux je ne veux plus en envoyer
d'ailleurs
en hongrie ou en pologne ou en un autre
endroit où j'aurais peur que les gens en
plus d'avoir déjà vécu le martyr
s'efface encore agressé mais je vais
mettre ces pays et ces pays
rigoureusement à contribution au des
politiques d'accompagnement de la
gestion migratoire et si ses payements
n'ont pas lieu alors il ne devra plus y
avoir de paiement pour ce pays du tout
et il y à il ya un divorce dans la
réalité la distorsion virtuel décès
réalité la perception des européens
c'est qu'ils ont nés sous la pression de
libération de l'afrique
et c'est tout à fait vrai que nous
sommes deuxièmes en minorité ces
audiences début l'effet de la situation
est parfaitement géré à blé par une
communauté des ventes de 8 est un membre
jusqu'à présent dans lesquels il y à des
états les plus riches du monde
c'est donc ainsi que se termine ce débat
aujourd'hui merci à tous les trois a dit
avoir participé nous avoir éclairé un
sur cette question épineuse évidemment
qui risque encore d'être au centre des
discussions dans les mois à venir
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis et
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur nos différents sites lcpan
public sénat et rtbf.be belle semaine à
tous et à très bientôt
[Musique]